[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
page myspace
pauthe il était amoureux de sa maîtresse
de ses eaux à l'envoyer les élèves sous
son bureau pour les punir
et il essayait donc de se faire punir le
plus haut ça ni briand rien obtenu c'est
dany brillant que ça tombe sur moi non
mais c'est vrai qu'à l'époque il y avait
des châtiments corporels
c'est vrai que la maîtresse elle nous
mettait sur le bureau quand sur soussou
et donc peu tâche et simon vit donc
enfin bon c'est c'était bizarre comme
moi je faisais exprès d'avoir des
mauvaises notes
ah ouais quand ils vous avez dû gérer 10
minutes sans courant sur scène c'était
très long ça marche les 2 premières
minutes les cinq premières minutes ça
après un peu compliqué est ce qu'on
appelle au courant de cet incident mais
jamais quoi pour un courant pas mal nous
ce qu'on a chanté avec dani c'est toute
la pluie tombe sur moi sacha distel je
fais comme si je ne sens pas je ne pense
pas qu'à toute la pluie tombe sur moi
comme ça sur moi à chaque instant est
pas mal
c'est un grand jaloux et fouillent
souvent le portable de sa conjointe
danielle vous dit dany brillant
philippe besson bien je l'aï brillance
et dany brillant c'est dany avance avant
avant à mon ancienne conjointe et depuis
votre nouvelle mais maintenant j'ai
travaillé sur la confiance en moi a très
bien et j'ai confiance en elle même
temps la nouvelle